Traductor: Daniel Medvedovsky
Revisor: Paula Motter
Los que nos criamos en ciudades chicas
estoy seguro de que alguna vez dijimos:
"No hay oportunidades acá.
No hay nada para hacer.
No puedo conseguir un trabajo estable.
No puedo progresar de
la manera que a mí me gustaría".
Y ¡ojo! Ahí siempre aparece
en escena una persona,
por lo general ya entrada en años, canosa
y con una panza acorde a su experiencia,
sin ofender a nadie,
que viene a recordarnos
que todo tiempo pasado fue mejor.
¿Es realmente esto así?
¿O tal vez no sabemos aprovechar
lo que la realidad tiene para ofrecernos?
Al pensar en esto,
inevitablemente me acuerdo
de mis amigos de toda la vida:
Juancho, Franco y Emanuel.
Esta foto que están viendo ahí
es del año 2009, cuando
íbamos a la secundaria.
¿Qué les puedo decir de mis amigos?
Que los quiero muchísimo,
que son como mis hermanos
y que son tres personas supercapaces
que, como no contaban
con los recursos necesarios
como para poder estudiar
lo que les gustaba,
se quedaron acá en la ciudad
y, vaya sorpresa,
hasta el día de hoy, no pueden
conseguir un trabajo
que les permita aproximarse
a cumplir sus sueños.
En cuanto a mí, que soy
el cuarto en esta foto,
la marca de la ausencia de oportunidades
también se hizo presente.
Mis viejos, que son trabajadores,
hicieron un esfuerzo sobrehumano
para que yo pudiera
estudiar lo que me gustaba,
porque sabían que
--y yo también lo sabía--
que si me quedaba acá
en la ciudad, podía estudiar algo,
pero probablemente, mi futuro como persona
iba a estar corto de oportunidades.
¿Alguna vez alguno de Uds.
se preguntó por qué pasan estas cosas?
Vivimos en pleno siglo XXI.
Estamos en el medio de este fenómeno
que conocemos como la globalización,
en el que los sucesos y avances se dan con
una velocidad que nos sorprende a todos
y derriban las fronteras y las barreras
que existen entre las personas.
En este contexto, las ciudades van
a ser cada vez más y más importantes.
Vamos a ser sinceros: son nuestro hogar.
Y las creamos y las recreamos
a cada paso de nuestra existencia.
Se estima que, para el año 2050,
un 68 % de la población mundial
va a vivir en una ciudad.
Por si ese número no les suena,
vendría a ser casi 7 de cada 10 personas
en todo el mundo.
Siete de cada diez.
Si cada vez más personas
eligen vivir en ciudades,
quiere decir que allí es donde tenemos
mayores posibilidades de progresar.
¿Qué es lo que explica, entonces,
que mientras algunas ciudades
parecen quedarse en el tiempo,
otras progresan, son vibrantes,
todo el mundo quiere visitarlas
y todo el mundo quiere vivir en ellas?
Acá les voy a contar una palabra clave
que quiero que les quede grabada
acá cuando salgan hoy por esa puerta
para volver a sus casas.
Estrategia.
Si queremos que la globalización
nos sirva a las ciudades
para traernos más
oportunidades a las personas,
necesitamos salir
estratégicamente al mundo.
Parte de mi preocupación
como futuro profesional en el campo
de las relaciones internacionales
pasa justamente por esto:
por conectar a las ciudades
con las oportunidades que el mundo
tiene para ofrecernos.
No de manera indiscriminada,
sino acentuando nuestras fortalezas,
nuestras potencialidades
y tratando de disminuir el impacto
que el mundo puede llegar a tener
sobre nuestras características
más vulnerables.
Ahora, Uds. me dirán:
¿Cómo se ve todo esto tan lindo que
les estoy contando en la vida real?
A través de proyectos concretos que
mejoran la calidad de vida de la población
y evitan la migración hacia otros
lugares en busca de un futuro mejor.
Otra vez, inevitablemente,
me acuerdo de ellos, de mis amigos.
Esta es una foto de hace unos meses atrás,
y a simple vista se puede
notar un par de cosas.
Por empezar, sumamos
un quinto amigo fiel al grupo.
¿Saben cuál es?
Las bebidas alcohólicas.
En segundo lugar, también podemos decir
que se da una especie de relación
inversamente proporcional.
A medida que va mejorando
la calidad de las fotos de los teléfonos,
los que estamos en ella
vamos desmejorando.
(Risas)
Algunos tienen un par de kilos de más,
y otros tenemos cada vez menos pelo,
pero ¿saben qué es lo que
compartimos hasta el día de hoy,
más allá del profundo afecto que
nos tenemos los unos por los otros?
La marca de la falta de oportunidades.
Franco, por ejemplo, que es
el que está a mi derecha en esta foto,
fue campeón nacional de las Olimpíadas
de Geografía en el año 2012.
Campeón nacional.
Pero, hoy en día,
por más que se quiera dedicar
a estudiar un profesorado de geografía,
no tiene tiempo porque tiene
que estar de lunes a lunes trabajando
simplemente para poder vivir.
Después está Juancho, que es
el que está a mi izquierda en la foto.
Justo ahí era su cumpleaños.
Juancho quería estudiar algo
relacionado al ámbito de defensa
para poder entrar en una de las fuerzas
de seguridad de nuestro país.
Pero, como no contaba
con esa posibilidad acá,
desde entonces va cambiando
de carrera en carrera
sin poder encontrar
lo que a él realmente le apasiona.
Y tampoco puede conseguir un trabajo
que le permita una cierta
independencia económica.
Por último, está Emanuel,
que es un genio en computación.
Pero no saben lo genio que es.
Te arregla cualquier cosa.
Pero, después de estar todo
el día trabajando en su local,
que construyó desde la nada misma,
va a la facultad a estudiar programación,
y no puede desarrollar su potencial
y seguir aprendiendo lo que le gusta
porque no cuenta con
las herramientas necesarias
por falta de presupuesto
en la universidad.
El tipo estudia programación
y no tiene ni los programas necesarios
en la computadora para poder estudiar.
Lo peor de todo esto
que les estoy contando
es que nosotros, como jóvenes,
no tenemos nada que nos haga
menos que el resto del mundo,
absolutamente nada.
Saben,
recientemente tuve la inmensa fortuna
de ser elegido entre un selecto grupo
de ocho jóvenes líderes a nivel mundial
para participar de un seminario
de una semana en Nueva Delhi,
la capital de India.
Viajé en representación de la Argentina,
fui el único argentino en ese evento
y demás está decir que fue
una experiencia increíble.
O sea, me voló la cabeza.
Aprendí muchísimo.
Pero si hay dos cosas que me gustaría
compartir hoy con ustedes
son las siguientes:
número uno, hay millones,
y esto nunca lo voy a poder
decir con el énfasis suficiente
para que ustedes puedan entenderlo,
pero hay millones
de oportunidades ahí afuera,
para todos los gustos
y para todos los colores.
Pero hay que estar dispuestos
a encontrarlas, no vienen solas.
Y número dos, pero no menos importante,
nuestros recursos humanos
como argentinos son brillantes.
No tenemos nada que envidiarle
ni a los jóvenes estadounidenses,
ni a los chinos, ni a nadie.
¿Saben qué es lo que los diferencia
a ellos que nosotros no tenemos?
Que tienen un Estado que está
ahí presente para salir al mundo
y traerles oportunidades a ellos
para que puedan desarrollarse.
Otra vez, ¿queremos mejores ciudades?
Salgamos estratégicamente al mundo.
Recuerdo cuando llegué
por primera vez a Rosario,
que me mudé para irme a estudiar,
con tres días para cumplir 18 años.
Era un nene, un nene asustado,
con muchísimo miedo.
Esto nunca lo pude contar en público,
porque me es muy difícil,
pero todos los que me rodean
saben por todo lo que tuve que pasar.
Es muy difícil dejar
tu ciudad, que es tu hogar.
Es como dejar un pedazo de tu corazón.
Hasta el día de hoy lo siento así,
y ya pasaron casi seis años.
Para que esto no te pase
a vos, ni a tus amigos,
ni a nadie que conocés,
es necesario brindarles
herramientas a nuestros jóvenes
para que se queden en sus ciudades
y puedan crecer desde allí.
Al fin y al cabo,
¿qué es más lindo que darle alas
a la ciudad que te vio nacer?
Y con una estrategia, lo podemos hacer.
Imagínense lo brillante
que habría sido Franco
si se hubiera podido dedicar
completamente a la geografía.
O Juancho, si al día de hoy estuviera
en una de las fuerzas de seguridad
de nuestro país.
O, para no irnos tan lejos, Emanuel,
si tuviera los programas necesarios
para poder seguir
aprendiendo lo que le gusta.
Así...
Así ¿eh?...
Así, se ve la falta de oportunidades.
Por si todo esto que les estoy contando
no les parece argumento suficiente
y quieren un ejemplo más...
Miren.
Mírenlo bien, ¿eh?
Este es el tatuaje que me hice
cuando por fin pude superar
la profunda depresión clínica en la que
caí por tener que irme de mi ciudad,
tras dos intentos de suicidio,
e innumerables secuelas psicológicas,
que me costó muchísimo,
muchísimo, superar.
Si queremos que estas
cosas dejen de pasar,
tenemos que salir
estratégicamente al mundo.
Por favor, no le pongamos
un punto final a nuestras ciudades.
Muchas gracias.